Right.
So far
stop. I'd like to bring out Mr.
Jason Mitchell from the CAS.
All right, daisy, come on in. Alright.
Mr Osei Jackson Jr.
Oh,
say Jackson Jr
I'm going to sit on the farm.
The farm. Yeah. Yup, Yup.
All right. Mr Corey Hawkins. Come on up.
Sorry.
Uh, steam director of the film.
F Gary Gray. Ladies and gentlemen
that Gary Gray
and producer of the film with no
introduction needed. Mr Ice Cube.
Yay.
Hey now. Hey now. All Right, welcome
gentlemen. Thank you guys for coming.
So we're going to have a nice
little moderate a discussion.
I'm going to open up to
Q and a for the audience,
so we'll have a nice little about
one hour or so conversation.
So hope you don't mind with that. Um,
and my first question to the group,
whoever wants to go first,
why did you say yes to the
story of straight Outta Compton?
Um, to me, you know,
it was just the perfect
time to tell this story.
So many people have,
uh,
been entertained off the Nwa
family tree for the last 25 years,
sir. And, uh, you know,
it was just like, yeah,
there's some people that that don't
even know I rap. You know what I mean?
As that's out in the world. And, uh,
so we want to show him the
origin where it all started,
what we went through and what we,
uh,
had to kind of endure,
uh, just to be ourselves.
And, uh, you know, to me it's a great
American story. It's a slice of life.
We want to show people the,
you know,
people know the when and the where
we wanted to show people why, like,
why do we make this kind of music?
And it was all because of the
environment that we grew up in. Compton,
south central La Watts, long
beach. And, uh, you know,
to me it was like the perfect story is,
is juicy enough to be a movie.
Uh,
so it had all the ingredients for a great,
great film.
Same question to a director.
Oh, well, for me, um, I
love a challenge. This movie
is something that, you know, kind of
fits in that category very easily.
I've never done a bio pic
before. Um, and it's, you know,
kind of one of those things where when
you get a chance to kind of take off your
world building hat in a world of fiction
and put on your journalist hat and
historian hat, um, this is an
amazing story. If you break it down,
uh,
this rags to riches,
there's triumph and tragedy as a lot
of the universal things that people can
really kind of tap into and no matter
where you're from. And so as a filmmaker,
I gravitated towards this.
And, um, even beyond that,
I felt like it was personal to me and I
feel like it's personal to me because I
grew up in this environment at that time,
not too far from ice cube and was involved
with their careers once they left Nwa
and direct and our music
videos and things like that.
So it was the perfect time for me.
Um,
and it's arguably the most
important film of my career.
Awesome. Thank you so much
for that. I have a question
about casting for the film.
Obviously we have these great gentlemen
here who played that we rose to the film.
Um,
and I had a question about casting.
So I read somewhere that you said that
this was a full circle moment for you in
this filming and authenticity
was key to the casting process.
What made you say Yes to these three
gentlemen for these roles that they were
able to play for this film?
Just hands down their performances,
you know, for, um, Jason,
you know, he has a lot of
experience, you know, in New Orleans,
but you know, in, in, in, in
the streets and, um, you know,
he brought a great performance,
but it also,
I could tell that he really
had a lot of, um, experience,
a lot of experience that I could
use and help to help create easy e.
One of the biggest things about casting
that role is not only his performance
but as a street credibility. And
so with Jason, he has, you know,
a lot of street credibility and
also he's a great actor. Um,
with Corey, you know, he has a
different background, you know,
went to Julliard and, and, um,
was doing Broadway and
Shakespeare and things like that.
And he came and completely
transformed into Dr Dre.
And so that was, um, a thing that was,
so it's just,
he just jumped off the screen in a way
that no one ever had regarding these
auditions. And it was great. And for Shea,
you know, he worked the hardest, you know,
he worked the hardest to get the role
and I'll let them tell you about their
journey. But authenticity was
the key and they brought it.
And to the cast. Actually, I
wanted to ask that question.
What was that journey like?
How did you guys become these characters
that we are so happy to get a chance to
see you pretty soon here?
Well,
I will say the hardest part about this
entire project was the prep. You know,
we put so much, so much
time in the prep, uh,
audition for this role for over two years,
uh,
before, you know, getting
called bags, different acting
coaches and Erin's Speiser.
He works with Wellsmith. Susan Batson
works with Nicole Kidman. And, uh,
once I got selected, even work with
Dustin Felder who works with will's kids.
So I've had a collective effort,
three different teachers,
three different techniques to really
form one project. And uh, you know, I,
I definitely couldn't do
this without them. Uh,
and they led to a chemistry test
where I meet these two right here and,
uh, you know, I had never done a
chemistry test. I never, you know,
this is my first go around and I
walk in there and a, I go to meet,
uh, the people that aren't, that
are around, I see a Jheri curl.
I'm going to go say what's up.
So I had over to do and I ask him,
you know, how I introduce myself?
How you doing? I'm going to say, uh,
you go for easy. And he says, no, I'm
going for cube. And then, you know,
after further,
after further review,
I see what kind of, you know, what kind
of a soup I am. And you know, it's just,
it's a,
it's a different kind of set up.
The competition look Gumbo with the same
ingredients. Exactly what I'm saying. So,
you know, there's, there's
two other cubes there. So the,
the pressure was always
there. And you know, once I,
once I booked the role, it was, it
was a weight lifted off my shoulders.
But even then, I knew the
real work had to start. Uh,
I had to look 17,
I went on a strict diet of,
of dirt and
grass and diet water and you know,
uh,
I lost 15 pounds in 24 days
of crossfit training and,
you know, shout out to PJ stall.
And we recorded the entire album.
It when we all went through
our own separate boot camps.
These guys can attest to their,
their hard work, but you know,
nothing about this film was easy,
but great morale makes great movies and
they chemistry I have with these guys
and the rest of the cast, it shows
in our film. And you know, it's,
it's all a test to the techniques
that we had to go through during prep.
Uh, for me, I'm, I'm like Gary
said, I was a at Julliard,
um, just doing Broadway
Shakespeare in New York and um,
I had heard about it and you know,
my agent was like, you know, this,
this movie straight Outta Compton.
I'm like, dope. Like, that's cool.
Like how can I get in there? Like, what
role can I play? He's like, go in for dre.
I said, oh wait, wait,
wait, wait. Come on.
Come on Dr Dre.
And uh,
so he was like, um, yeah, yeah. You know,
we got the audition set up and everything.
I say, listen, I'm not going
in for it because first of
all, I don't look like him.
I don't sound like him. I don't
think I, you know what I mean?
I just don't think I can do that.
It's same things that get in your head as
an actor, um, you getting your own way.
Right. So he, he was like,
okay, okay, okay, but I'm
gonna set up the appointment.
I said, no, call me back eight
o'clock that night. And he's like,
the casting director called and
said, you didn't come in. And I said,
I told you I wasn't going broke
because, um, but you know,
I knew,
I knew that this project was going to
be special because of who was involved
because Gary was involved
in cute was involved and dre
was involved in the other,
you know, members of Nwa and
easiest widow and, you know, and,
and so one thing led to another, I
skyped with Gary. Um, and then ended up,
you know, thank you man. Uh,
flying out to La to do the studio test
and he don't run studio tests like normal
people run studio test.
Like he had about five,
six cameras rolling on for one set up.
All, you know, and it was, it was crazy.
It was, it was wild, but it was surreal.
And all I remember thinking was, you know,
looking back at a time when I was doubting
myself then while I was in it and I
was like, Oh yeah, I'm about to,
I'm about, I'm about to go on this,
you know what I mean? I'm, I'm, I'm ready
now. I'm hungry. I want it. Um, and then,
yeah, we, we linked up and the work began,
but there was so much work before we
could even start the prep work before we
could even start principal photography.
So we'll talk about that. But, you know,
love me.
I was Kinda like in a situation
where I felt like, um,
you know why I had done a couple of
active projects here and there, you know,
but I was like Kinda day plan,
you know,
cause I'm from New Orleans and I'd never
even been to California and nothing
like that. But, um, it kind of
started the pickup, you know,
what my acting career and I've done two
movies with Mark Wahlberg. I did, um,
broken city and contraband. So I was
kind of like on the radar for universal.
There was like this kid, just a good
dude. Like he, you know, he worked hard,
he'd come, he'd do his work and he just,
he chill, you know, so there was like,
maybe we should read them
for a lead. So, you know,
they sent it to me and I
was like, easy, Eh, Ooh,
Ooh. So, you know, needless
to say, you know, I,
I took the opportunity serious, I did my
homework, you know, did what I could and,
um, I really just went in, like
put my foot in it, you know,
and the lady I read with,
she's a lady named Megan Lewis
from New Orleans and, um,
she's normally like really,
really like straight forward.
It really serious, you know, she's
really Boston if anybody from Boston,
she's really, really Boston,
something like, alright, you know,
and I went and read with her and,
um,
we had this, this, this different
kind of vibe in the room that day.
I remember her giving me like the
double high five and all that,
and she walked me to the car. I
was like, this is no, you know,
so I was already feeling good about it,
but then it took them like almost a
month to call me back. So I was like, ah,
maybe I didn't get it, you know. Then when
they did call me back, they were like,
Gary wants you to out, you
know, for, for, um, a car back.
And I'd be like, wait, wait,
can't you still like not get the road
when you get a call back? They was like,
yeah, that was like, ah, well you
know the way my bank account set up,
oh no, y'all might got to get back at
me, you know? And it was like, well,
you know, we'll call you back, you
know, see what we could do about it.
So they called me back like 30 minutes
later. It was like, man, Gary loves you.
He wants to Skype with you. I'll
be like for him. Ah, you know,
so I went down and did it
and we skyped for like,
I was 17 minutes and probably
some seconds, you know,
but I was like, you know,
whatever, you know. So I
just remember, you know,
cause I had to do this scene where I'm
like breaking down something like crying
and he's like, breathe, breathe.
When I'm like finally like
I'm not nervous no more. Well,
the audition is over now,
so I feel our breath and I'm like,
I just bust out laughing.
So I all these other voices busts out
laughing and I can't really see his face
on the Skype, like, what's
happening, what's happening?
So I never heard the words I booked,
you know,
so like later on they
called me and they're like,
we're going to fly you out for a studio
test. And that's where I meet these guys.
But unlike them, I was the only easy
e. But in my mind, I'm thinking, man,
maybe they too big, they have to come
to a studio test like this. You know,
I'm like, you know, so I'm like,
I'm on full pit mentality. I'm like,
I never thought I got the role. So we're,
we're going through like days of it,
you know. But through that I could like
feel this chemistry going on between us.
It was like Gary could throw something
in the mix of wedges. We was like,
Paul Ryan, is that it? You know what I
mean? It was, it was crazy. And you know,
shout out to the guys who didn't get it,
but we already knew what was that
we already knew, you know? And, um,
yeah, we went into a boot camp that was,
that was some crazy, cause
I like this guy, you know,
I like to the dirt and lemon
grass that he was eating.
We had to eat 4,000 calories a day,
boxing training,
then weight training. Then I had
to go learn how to do, you know,
walk and talk like easy e and perform
and do our ladder and record it,
then rehearsal and then do it
again the next day for two months.
So yeah,
it was for real.
Okay. So this next question is
for Cube, obviously in a Gary,
what was it like having Nwa on set
with you guys during this process?
Like how was that experience reliving
this story with your, with your team,
with the crew and with
the whole production cat?
I think that was, you know, the, one of
the funnest parts was to see them perform.
Uh,
and we got this big arena full of people
and they was actually going to get up
there and do it for real.
And I've never been to an NW,
it's kind of cool. You know, I was
like, damn, you know, it is, you know,
it was impactful. It was
powerful. And I'm like, man,
this is powerful for for 2015,
you know,
I can imagine how it was for 1989.
Uh,
it was just a treat to see
it from afar and Kinda and,
and look, be looking at
us, but, but you know,
actually be an audience or bottom
monitors with Gary. And it was just,
uh, you know, I wanted them, you know,
some of them most amazing giddy feelings
that we've had with each other for as
me ran yella tray, you know,
seeing them up there, you know,
we were just like kids, man. And it
was like we were just like old times,
so it was so fun.
Um,
but I did feel like we was in a back
to the future movie. I see. You know,
I felt like we was going to
change history if, uh, if,
if O'Shea water wrong hat and shit,
everybody started disappearing
and Shit, you know, so,
so, you know, we just,
just, it was just a great,
great experience that I'll never forget
that we all went through the fire
together and we bonded.
I'm bonded with these guys just like
I'm bonded with Nwa because they are Nwa
now for everybody who looks on the screen,
who don't pick up a documentary,
you know, when they see Nwa,
they got to see these guys. So they are
as they, they're an extension of, of us.
So it's a beautiful thing.
Do you, so was the question, how was it
having the real Nwa on the set? Yeah,
well, you know, for me it
helped out a lot. For me,
the best film making is,
you know, uh, you know,
when you have someone at the helm who
just gives you details and really pays
attention to detail and just does all the
research and the homework to transport
you to another time and another world
and make you feel like you're there.
And so to have Nwa on the set.
For me it was great because I'm getting
firsthand accounts of all these moments
in the studio, all the fights, all
the great moments, all of the pottery,
all of the stuff that was going on. And
so when you watch the movie, you, you,
you, you really get a sense that,
wow, these guys were brothers. Um,
you got a sense of the anger when they
were angry and it wasn't something that
you just, um, I was at Google
and you know what I mean?
Like I don't wanna say it like that, but
I'm just saying like, you can go beyond,
you know, Google's though, don't
get me wrong. Nope, of course.
Google is Hashtag Google's dope.
No, but I'm saying you get,
you get details from the guys that you
can't get on Wikipedia or online and
those details really help
the movie feel authentic.
We did Google a lot too.
Right.
And funny you should ask that.
So we are in a technology company,
we are at Google. Right. What
would make in this process,
what would making this film in like 1995
91 have been like with the ad says a
social media and how do you compare
that today to what we have today?
Like what do you think Nwa in the story
would have been like with technology and
with social media? The way it
was day back in the Nwa is days.
Oh man, you know, everything would have
just happened a lot faster than I can.
I can't imagine that because you
know, it, it happened fast for us.
So we thought we was
just going to be local.
So we thought our music was so rough and
so underground that we would just be,
you know, underground artists and
never really get to this level and a,
so everything would have happened at a,
at a breakneck speed.
Uh, so, you know, it's, it's,
it's interesting to think about,
I'm kind of glad it happened the way it
did. You know, because you never know.
One little change,
one little thing in history and you know,
might not turn out like this. Uh,
and you know, this is a story.
And Ana and I kept mentioning that
the reason we want to tell this story,
cause we all been entertained
by Nwa for over 25 years.
Uh, you know, know Nwa. There's
no poison. The hood movie,
No boys in the hood movie,
No Friday movie,
which Gary Directed, uh, and we did
together, you know what I'm saying?
And so these things,
uh,
these things all coincide with each other
and it's a great origin story because,
you know, people love snoop and them and
them and all these things and you know,
they bumping they beats and all that.
And we wouldn't have
none of that without Nwa.
We might not even have
shea junior without Nwa.
So, you know, everybody
world is that, you know, so,
uh,
you know,
is really all about showing
people where it came from and,
and celebrating it in and making people
a part. You know, the way Gary shot it,
you feel like you were in the studio with,
you feel like you rolling with us.
You feel like you're being produced
by doctor dre. So, you know,
these are experiences that we understand,
we felt and we want the audience to
experience what we experienced. And, uh,
you know, Gary did a magnificent
job in capturing, you know,
everything that we want to show.
Thank you.
And this question is for you Gary.
Yeah.
It felt like La and south central Los
Angeles and Compton or actually the sixth
member of Nwa and this film,
it felt like that was actually a
character of the film and the way that you
really took care of filming
and doing those things there.
What was that process like
actually filming most of the movie,
particularly in the Los Angeles area,
home, southern California earlier?
Well, it was crucial, you know, like
you said, it I, Los Angeles, Compton,
south central, you know, they,
they do feel like the sixth member
of Nwa and it's because all of the
things that happen in that area,
in that era really forging Nwa, all
the good stuff, all the bad stuff,
all of the things that they went through
and you hear it and their raps you
hearing in their poetry. And so, um,
being able to open up and show not only
wide shots of Los Angeles with the palm
trees and you know, and um, how kind
of beautiful but dangerous it is.
Um, being able to tap into the
street culture with the car,
custom cars and even our atmosphere,
our extras,
all these things lend itself to making
it feel like Los Angeles and the 80s.
And it's just about authenticity.
You know,
when you watch the Scorsese movie
and he does a casino, Vegas is the,
a character in a movie.
And um,
all of the different things that you
get the nuances from Los Angeles really
helps serve the story.
And that's why it was important.
So this question is for the task mates.
What were your favorite moments from set?
I'm glad you said favorites with
the NAS babies. With the nurse.
Yeah. That's so dope. But um, they met
me. Has So, so, so many good moments,
you know? But, um, that cube said like,
he never been to an Nwa
concert and I'm not a rapper,
so I lived with della because her before,
you know,
but I went through this
process of kind of like,
yeah,
being like y'all on TV,
you know, to be in like
super confident when I'm
around these guys. You know,
they was the same people who were like,
y'all are the dues for the job.
You know what I mean?
But until you see somebody come out,
the character that you normally see
them in, it don't really feel like that,
you know? But when we did those concerts,
you can see them like, yeah, you know,
you could see him in that zone, like
their eyes light up and you're like, wow,
that's what's up. You know? So
like, it was good. You know,
it's like that type of
feeling that you have,
you get to like really do that rock star
life for a minute. You know what I mean?
It was just, it was a famous
moment. It was super dope. Yeah.
Uh, who's, who's seen the film.
Okay.
All right. Ooh, y'all
in for a surprise. All
right, well then, uh, you
know, that, that, that, that
changes things a little bit. Um,
I, one of my favorite times on said,
uh, it's in the trailer. Uh, you know,
I, I'm pretty upset at a, at
a man in an office, you know,
kind of,
I kind of take it out a little bit,
but one of the highlights of us film
and the movie was Paul Giamatti bouncin
with a BB and some gold ropes on
to why g hitting the switches that,
uh, you know, Paul Paul Giamatti was the,
the veteran and the rookie locker room.
You know,
he had things to say to all of us
that build confidence in us. His,
uh, yeah, Tom Brady, uh, his,
uh, he ain't Cheetah. He, uh,
he told me,
you know,
he would tell me,
he would tell me about his father,
who was a famous baseball player. Like
is if you, if you look him up, you know,
Mr Giamatti has a huge role in baseball,
but he was, he was telling me, uh,
the amount of pressure he would feel if
he had to play his father and in a role.
So, you know, it would, he,
he told us all things that,
that built up something and then say, you
know, I appreciate everything. Football.
Yeah. Give it, um,
it was uh, it was probably, I mean it
was, I think it was definitely the,
the concert scenes. You know, it just had
to be the concert scenes because again,
I'm not a rapper either, so no, I'm saying
to be up there. But the thing about dre,
he was Sorta, you know, on
the tables back in the day.
So it was just cool to be up there
really like spinning and like,
cause I had to actually go through that
and learn how to Dj literally learn
every single thing, every
single producing, you know,
everything about it. But um,
those were the moments that we really
felt like Nwa. And then to have,
like you said, La is, is like a competent,
it's like a six character in a movie.
You know,
we had people bring in as plates,
onset of food and sitting on
the rooftops and you know,
hold my baby,
you know,
stealing easy east
chairs come back though.
I'm thinking most people would take the
chip back. They take the whole chair.
I'm like, whoa. Really? Was it was,
it was positivity though. You know,
it was just a lot of positive energy.
And it's funny because in the news and
the media, everybody tries to say, Oh,
you know all this,
you know hootenanny is that a word?
You know,
Hashtag [inaudible]
movie, you know, all
this craziness around it.
Ooh Man.
Craziness around surrounding the movie.
But every day we got a new nickname.
Now you're officially
stop this right now.
I'll give you a man who here
what they call me like you have,
you have a nickname. Oh Gee, doctor.
Who'd Nan who?
I think I heard that since
like the dukes of Hazzard, 1983
Oh man,
I'm going to know inside job forever.
I can't even go on it. It was
just, it was real positive,
real path causing.
Awesome
for you cube. Um, Compton, that's
where you're from. That's your city,
that's your hometown.
What does straight out of Compton,
what does this movie mean for your
philanthropic efforts that you're for the
city and how can this film success tied
to those programs that you're running
out there?
Well, you know, it's like, you know,
Compton and south central Long Beach,
it was like we was trying to really put
the west coast on the map, you know,
before Nwa,
uh,
it was only one real west coast rapper
getting any light and that was ice t and.
M.
So we was trying to,
to inject some kind of
pride into the city, uh,
before easy. He really
pushed for Compton. You know,
people was, people didn't even want to
admit they was from Compton, you know,
it was like,
it was so bad and everybody knew that
it was such a raw area that people
wouldn't even say they was from there.
They were saying it was from Carson.
You know what I'm saying? Which
is right by Compton. And, um,
so he injected pride and
you know, by, you know,
other people, Sam Brooklyn's in the house,
Queens in the house. And we was like,
Yo,
now Compton's in the house and you know,
people were Compton with pride. Now I
see my man with the Compton on his hat.
So it's a,
it's a badge of honor and people know that
there's talent there and uh, you know,
it's just really about, given
that talent, inspiration,
showing people that we come
off the same streets you do,
and it ain't just comped and it can be
anywhere and ain't gotta beat your hood.
It could be the suburbs,
just do it, you know,
just have passion and a,
have a drive,
have a commitment and have some discipline
and you can get a lot of great things
done. So that's what we're really
trying to push. And, um, you know,
dre has really stepped up for
the city of Compton as well.
You know, he's, uh, you know,
donate in a lot of, is, uh,
I guess money from this new
album to Compton. And, you know,
we're figuring things to, to do
for the city as well as, you know,
easies uh, kids, you know,
his kids are left behind
and all when he passed away.
So we just trying to hold the
legacy up. That's all. That's great.
That's beautiful.
Yeah. Um, for me, um,
I've worked with dre over the last four
years or so. Um, it, give it back to,
to Compton specifically.
Um,
but I have a youth center actually called
the Tom Bradley Youth Center on Pico
that I've adopted and over the last
decade have been instrumental in keeping
that place up and going and running
and working with a lot of, uh,
kids without parents. And, um,
there's a elementary school and watch
called a hundred clustery elementary
school and also Verbum dei high school
where I put a film program and, and,
and those places in order to show kids
that they can do other things, um,
that's creative like they did,
they picked a pen and pad
in a microphone. So, you know,
we sent cameras and editing equipment
and stuff there and been doing that for
quite a long time.
No, it's crazy. I feel like all you gotta
do is touch one life man. Like in, in
what they're doing is, um, it's,
it's powerful because they have a,
it's a family tree, you know,
that they create it. So, you know,
we're an extension of that, you know, of
their legacy and, and hopefully this film,
you know, continues that too,
but like just what they've done,
you know what I mean? In terms of
giving back and just showing up.
You touch one person,
that person gets touched millions that,
you know what I mean? So I
just think that's huge. Okay.
Well we can keep down on a hootenanny.
Good luck Cory.
Good luck Corey.
So it's been about 25 plus years
since the release of f the police.
And um,
this movie did such a brilliant job of
depicting a police brutality and what
that element did to people
in the cities of Compton,
in Los Angeles and to people all over
the country. What, what has changed?
What do you think has
changed between then and now,
and what can we do to really elevate
this conversation and to support projects
like straight outta Compton
that are doing this as well?
Well, not enough has changed, you know,
and this movie really highlights that,
that uh, uh, the more things
change, the more they stay the same.
Um, I think what, what insights you,
when you see it in our movie
is the fact that you know,
that these guys are trying
to do the right thing.
So the humiliation is that much more,
you know, and I think
it's more humiliation, uh,
is really the,
the type of abuse that we highlighted.
Uh,
um, so, you know, I just think
we got a weed it out. Um,
and it's,
it's very funny and I just
don't understand it that
a guy can go into a church
or whatever,
kill all these people and they walk him
out like he's the president, you know,
and bulletproof vests and shit.
And you know, I was like, whoa.
And then the little 18 year old kid,
the mouse off at the cop,
he's the one with the black
eye and a busted nose.
So I just think they need to refocus
the anger on real criminals that do real
crime. You know, if you want to beat up
on somebody beat up on a child molester,
you know what I mean? Not The kid that's
a little drunk coming from is, you know,
uh, coming from the party or whatever.
So you know, these things, you know,
it's just uh, uh, a mentality
that we got to correct.
Okay. Now I think the solutions are, uh,
more body cameras, Dash
Cams, all this stuff,
just to be able to hold
people accountable,
be able to see the real picture of
what went down and it just hold people
accountable. You know, everybody
crossed the line every now and then,
even regular citizens cross the line.
So when they cross the line,
you just hold them accountable
and it's starting to happen.
And, you know, I don't,
I don't think no cop want to go out in
the day and then end up on CNN and later
that night. I don't think nobody
wants to do that. So I just think,
you know,
those kind of things are
helping officers think twice.
And I hope our movie helps people to
think twice that, you know, you can't,
you can't, uh, pain our
community with a broad brush.
I think there were all the same,
you know,
for all the statistics that they show
about the crime in our community,
40%,
this 30% that just know that
there's 60% that don't do it,
there's 70% that don't do it.
So it's more law abiding citizens
in the hood and criminals and,
and um, that's really what we just
trying to show is that, you know,
don't paint us all with the same brush
and a treat us fair like human beings.
That's all.
Well, I think you, you're really, he
really hit the mark, you know. Um,
you know, we've done a lot of talking.
We've done a lot of protesting.
I think we should start focusing on a
solutions. You know, I'm cautiously,
cautiously optimistic that a lot of the
headlines are going to put pressure on
our leaders and our leaders in law
enforcement to make change in the culture.
This is not just one cop at a time is a,
you know,
you wouldn't do it if you didn't feel
like it was okay to do it, you know.
So we have to change the culture.
You know, you come to Google,
it's not just about a job,
it's a culture and that's why you guys
are who you are. And so successful.
So in police and law enforcement culture,
there has to be a shift. And that style,
it starts at the top, not just what
the guy who's having a bad day.
And so I think that if we consider putting
pressure on our lawmakers to change
federal law and make it a felony to
tamper with audio recordings and video
recordings and things like that.
And so if you're caught up in that,
you go to jail and you'll spend time with
those criminals that you're trying to,
um, um, you know, keep behind bars,
make it a real penalty, not
just, you know, uh, you know,
consequences of an invisible
investigation and make it a real penalty.
And I think if we start,
stop burning down our cities,
stop just talking about it.
I mean the conversation is good,
but let's on solutions.
Um,
I believe there was a study in Rialto,
California where they put body cams and
dash cams on every officer they are in,
basically they'll
complaints went down by 88%,
and the incidents went down by 60% over
the course of actually just eating a
year, I believe, or something like that.
And so let's start focusing on
solutions less, not just, you know,
channel our anger and, and, and,
and, and conversation on protesting.
Let's look at real solutions. And
I think that's part of it. Um,
my mother is a police officer and,
uh,
it was one when I got to sit and she
came to visit set, they were like,
you might have to recast.
Okay.
Right.
She, she, so she's a cop,
but, uh, she's a fan of their,
their music. She's a fan of them,
you know, she's a fan of the culture.
She's a fan of, uh, of,
of Sam positivity, um,
in which she does in the community.
And I think a lot of departments can
take a lesson from it is, is, you know,
her and her partner, they started this
thing in DC. I'm from DC, um, and,
and it's called Friday nights out.
And basically they set up these stages
around different parts. You know,
th th the trouble areas in DC,
you know,
where I grew up and they allow kids
to come out and like if you wrap,
you can get on stage and you have a
place to do it. You know what I'm saying?
If you seeing you, you know, whatever,
if you, you know what I mean? If you,
if you'd like to do art,
they bring out artists and they
work with the kids on Friday nights,
the nights where people, you know, can
get in a little bit of trouble. You know,
they like to do that. And it's the
police officers who are down there. So,
you know, she likes the art. So she
gets up there and does it with them.
And you know, it's little
things like that. They're
really change, you know, the,
the, the, the community and
because they're supposed to be,
to protect the community, they supposed
to know when they walked the beat,
they supposed to know who live in this
house and who live in that house and
understand what you can understand and
have that dialogue with the community.
Then you can, you can, you can
open it up, you know what I mean?
The possibilities are endless and the
possibilities for negativity that stop,
you know what I mean? Um, but I think
that's just one little, you know,
the one thing I like to add too is just,
let's not mistake,
I don't want anyone to be
mistaken about our story.
And the message within a story. This
is not an anti cop movie, right?
It's an anti criminal movie. You know,
excessive force is a crime. All right?
And,
um,
ultimately we know there's a lot of
peaceful warriors out there that put on a
badge,
but on a gun and that will help us.
And I think most of them
fit into that category.
So for other cook good cops that are
out there, we're not talking about,
you were talking about that people who
have the propensity to go overboard and,
um, do what they're doing.
That's what we're complaining
about. Yeah. Yeah. Let's,
let's not get it twisted.
Yeah.
Somebody break in my house.
I'm calling the cops.
I'm not calling the homeys,
not calling Gary.
I'm
calling the cops. So you know what I
mean? It don't, don't get it twisted.
We just want to clean up a couple of,
couple of missteps,
a couple of little over aggression, you
know, uh, it's just want to clean that up.
But you know, we were not anti
law enforcement by no means,
no means.
So we're going to start lining up
people in the audience for Q and. A.
So if you have some questions,
please start lining up now.
And I wanted to wrap this up today you
guys, thank you so much for coming.
Thank you.
You guys are having,
it's definitely doable,
right?
My last question is a quick rapid fire.
You're going to start with,
I start with straight out of, and you're
going to tell me your answer. So ready.
And I'll go around.
So straight out of Long Beach,
Compton,
south central Washington,
DC answers and I'm
straight out of the water.
Thank you guys so much
for the audience.
Hey guys. Hey, where I come
from? Hootenanny's a real word,
just hey and hats off to Julliard.
Major accomplishment. Love
that. You did that and see,
and you hear what these guys,
it's absolutely amazing to see if y'all
didn't hear the first Hootenanny's a
real word, right? Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Go. We're
going to use it every day.
Um, Mister Cube, your highness.
I love it.
No, it's like when I saw this coming
today, I heard you guys, I'm Jason Ellis.
A couple of days ago,
which fascinating interview the
child did with him on Sirius.
But everybody was stunned that I was
coming over here to talk to you all,
at least on my team.
So is there any tangent that could
get a picture with y'all too?
Prove I was actually here.
We only taken one picture is yours.
Come on up. We'll take yours. Have it.
She's lap collab.
Google is,
hey, can't believe you up here because it
all it is hootenanny everybody say who?
Nanny Hashtag
[inaudible]
so maybe you'll take two people,
not just young and just, uh,
so this question actually is for a
doctor. Hootenanny no, I'm just kidding.
Keep Rolling.
No, it's not going to end for a log time.
You got out of the side that, yeah. Uh,
first of all,
I just want to say a raider nation.
We are always in forever. Yeah.
So I'm from southern California,
born and raised in Barstow and grew
up really truly with a hip hop is as
everything that pretty much got me to
the place where I am now. And music,
like express yourself and lethal injection
and all these incredible albums that
you created, um, had so much
to do with where I am today.
So I just wanted to hear a little bit
about all of your musical influences and
what really inspires you and
inspired you in your role.
Uh, I'm completely
inspired by him. You know,
it was all about, you know, a lot of
people didn't want me to get the role,
but he wanted me to get the Bra and
that's really what I needed. Um, he, uh,
he's had my back forever.
You know,
I just wanted to make sure I had his
back on something and in everything,
you know,
as far as what I'm doing in my career
in film and whatever I choose to do
further and music is to further
build on this empire that he started,
you know, and, uh, I'm just thankful
that I'm given the opportunity to do so.
And, uh, you know, I'm
gonna make it rock. Okay.
Well, I'm a music dude, man. I'm a
really, really, really good fat to have,
you know? And I'm like, I kill
it in the shower. Awesome.
I'm one of them dudes. You
know what I mean? Like, like
music is a part of my life,
you know? And they just, it make
everything go together for me, you know?
And as far as like straight outta Compton
goes by US rerecording the whole album,
I think he put me in a different mind
frame of where I am today, you know,
because I kind of view
us as like the old Nwa,
like,
you know,
the situation they were in because it's
so much controversy that surrounded this
movie and all that.
But it's still like a super positive
thing that we're doing no matter what may
come out of it. It's still words and
it's still art that we'd given them,
you know? And it's like, it's, she
mentioned in that forever, you know?
So for me to be a part of that is like,
it's the best to say that these,
you know, so yeah, that's what's up.
Yeah. Same here, man. I'm, I'm,
uh, I'm just a fan of music,
so for sound good. If it's,
if it's honest, if it's, you know, coming
from where you come from, then, then it's,
it's good. I rock with it.
But, um, in terms of like,
just inspiration and in
playing this character, I just
look up to these guys now,
you know,
it's like I really see where they came
from and I see what they're doing now.
And I'm like, I want to do that. I want
to be a movie mogul. You know what I mean?
I want wanna,
I want to own a business.
I want to be a billion.
They're so freaking bad.
It's so crazy. Like to see the
possibilities, you can do it,
you know? And, uh, it's, it's just great
to be a part of this, this family tree.
So that was great.
Musical influences.
Uh,
George Clinton and parliament Funkadelic,
you know,
they really showed us how
to not care and be yourself,
you know, and just do what you
feel. And, you know, they so,
you know, light years ahead of a time. Um,
still, you know, that music
is still intricate in,
you know,
complex and free of any kind of,
uh, chains or musical, um, I guess,
uh, parameters, you know, they just
do what they feel. And, uh, so,
you know, George Clinton,
parliament funkadelic,
Rogers App, uh, James Brown,
you know, uh, these guys are,
they are a blueprint and you know,
we are an extension of what
they have done. You know,
you got P funk, you got g
funk, you know, so there it is.
For me,
I always kind of just loved the artists
that just stood up and had the courage
to go against the grain.
And Marvin Gaye, me,
the album called what's going on when he
was making balance and he just stood up
and said, you know what, there's
so many things going on around me.
I can't just talk about love
stories and things like that.
And that's an album that he
got a lot of problems, um,
and a lot of flak for, um, for,
for creating and then, you know, then
putting it out. But it's a classic,
and I'm not just saying
this cause cube is here,
but he made an album like that called
death certificate where he talked about
the social ills around,
um,
where we grew up and just stood up and
with all the controversy and all the
judgment that came,
um,
I just like I'm inspired by artists that
stand up and even in the midst of all
of the pushback and the criticism and
controversy and speaks to what we go
through. And I'm Marvin Gaye's, you
know, my number one and you know,
Cube doesn't notice, but you know,
he definitely inspired me as well.
Now we know.
So I am just so excited that you guys are
here like presenting to this audience.
I'm just so glad that we
had this opportunity to see
you and listen to you and
your actual like perspectives.
And to that end, um,
just real quick queue.
I cannot believe I'm addressing you.
The person who wrote no
Vaseline cause that was insane
as an eighth grader.
Like it was crazy.
But the question that I
do have is for Cuban Gary,
how do you feel about
people taking your work?
Kind of out of the context that it's in
and enjoying it like mainstream America
enjoying it but not really understanding
what it's about or where it's from.
Like the example with um bye Felicia.
How that's become like a great phrase
for everyone to use and then they don't
really know that it's
from Friday or who Felicia
[inaudible].
That's ridiculous to me.
So how do you feel about things that
when they happens like that when it's co
opted by,
like the main stream culture,
you know, I don't mind as much,
you know, cause I figure to
the cool people in know what
I'm talking about, you know,
and everybody else and everybody
else need to catch up. You know,
that's how I feel.
It's like a paint and you know,
once you put it on the wall everybody's
going to have a different kind of
interpretation of what you were
trying to say or do. And that's fine.
That's what it's all about.
You know,
I can't tell you what to
think about my song, you know,
you gotta tell me what you think about my
song. You know, all I could do is do it,
do it how I feel it.
And you know, when Nwa,
I don't want to say that we was,
you know,
this super positive political group
that went to go politically changed the
world. No, we,
we had a lot of records that
was just straight raw, uh,
and probably wasn't positive at all,
but they was honest. And I think that's
why people love us because we was honest.
We wasn't worried about that part.
We wasn't worried about the people
that didn't like us. You know,
we were just worried about
what we liked. And, you know,
a lot of more people was on our
side than against us. And, uh,
that's why we still here. So, you know,
it doesn't bother me at all that
people misinterpret anything that I do.
You know, it's all are like he said,
you're just expressing yourself. So, um,
I couldn't put it any better than cute.
Put It,
you just express yourself and let it be
what it's going to be. And that's it.
The people who don't know that by Felicia
is Friday or the same people who are
Twitter say, aw man, Kanye is going
to blow this Paul Mccartney dude up.
Or Man,
thank God Katy Perry found new artists
like missy Elliot for the Superbowl
halftime. They probably, you know,
those people will probably watched
straight outta Compton and be like, oh,
this should be a real group. You
know, so, you know, that's, that's,
that's my piece on that.
So real quick, I just want to
thank you guys for coming by. Yeah,
I'm striped from comp to actually I grew
up on Maple Avenue, east elementary,
Roosevelt middle, all that
stuff. Um, so they're kind of,
I have a question specifically for a
Cuban for Gary. Um, when I was growing up,
a lot of like my friends and staff really
bought into Gangsta rap and they kind
of figured that there were
really only two options, right?
It was either going to be music or I was
going to be sports and like I've tried
to go back to the community just
to tell them about, well, you know,
you could do programming, you could do,
you know, other kinds of arts, you know,
you go on to Madison and
all that kind of stuff.
Like what would you guys say to maybe
those youth in Compton Long Beach,
you know, you know from where we're
from that think that music and um,
in sports their only option.
Well, I like to speak to
that just because, um,
I grew up in south central
La and I don't have a degree.
I didn't go to college and I went into
film, you know, I didn't, you know,
do all the things that, or, or at least
I didn't feel like I had limited options.
You know, I just found something I
liked and I just stuck with it. And um,
you know, you can get in the
program or whatever you, you know,
you want to get into. And I
was on the streets. You know,
part of the reason why a lot of
the work we've done together,
it feels authentic cause
cause I was really there and
either witnessed it or um,
you know, was involved in it.
So you can make a transition.
It's about what you create.
You can create your own universe.
And I know it sounds Cliche, but
it's real and I've, you know,
like right now I'm super nerding
out on model airplanes, you know,
and I'm building seriously.
And it was telescopes down.
No, it was, I mean I, I've gone through
a few phases, you know, studying the,
the surface of the moon
and things like that.
And then I w I build my planes
and drones and cameras and,
and, and I just started flying
airplanes so you can, you know,
be wherever you from and then just have
the courage to make the transition.
I love with cubes done where
he's gone from, you know,
gangster rap to political rap and
back and to movies into, you know,
giving people opportunities.
And he's a family man,
and he's not afraid to stand up and say,
I'm going to make the
transition regardless of what
you think. You can judge me.
It doesn't matter. So from people
from Compton or wherever you from,
just don't be afraid to be judged.
It's okay.
And there's all kind of,
it's all kind of,
here's what I tried to stress that it's,
you know, whatever industry you love,
there's a thousand jobs around
that industry. You know,
you don't have to be in front
of the camera. Matter of fact,
that Karen man had told me when I was
shooting Boyz in the hood, he said,
I've been sitting behind this
camera 35 years. I shot everybody.
I see him come and go in front of me.
I'm still here.
So sometimes the jobs that are the
real jobs is behind the scenes.
So we got to just encourage, you
know, everybody's not gonna go on,
uh, you know, be the player
or be on stage. But man,
everybody needs a light man and
engineer a, a coach, uh, agent,
uh, you know, so there's a
million different jobs, um,
that's surrounded around the dreams
that they should start. You know,
a lot of guys start at the bottom and
then ended up at the top. Uh, you know,
it's one coach, uh, used to
coach. The heat's still do.
He started off doing the video
play back now he, the head coach,
so olster yeah.
So it's a thing where you got a,
use your talents wherever they may lie
to get you in the door and they not,
you know, everybody's not going to
be, you know, in front of the camera.
It's all about finding
where you can fit in,
in the industry that you love and, and,
uh, how you going to be happy at that.
So, you know, it's,
it's really encouraging people
to look at all aspects of a,
of an industry that they want to get in.
All right.
Thank you gentlemen so much for your time.
[inaudible]
yeah.